.
SHE'LL ALSO ALSO HELP TO SOME
DEGREE WITH THE MID-TERM
ELECTIONS.
MORE FROM OUR WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT KATE BENNETT.
>> Reporter: JILL BIDEN MARKING
ONE YEAR AS FIRST LADY IN A
FAMILIAR PLACE, ON THE ROAD.
THURSDAY IT WAS NEW JERSEY TO
TALK ABOUT EDUCATION.
AND AFTER A LENGTHY AND AT TIMES
CONTROVERSIAL PRESS CONFERENCE
FROM THE PRESIDENT THE DAY
BEFORE, SUPPORTING HER HUSBAND.
>> BUT I WANT YOU TO KNOW THIS
BECAUSE I FEEL THIS SO STRONGLY,
YOU WERE RIGHT TO PUT YOUR FAITH
IN MY HUSBAND JOE ONE YEAR AGO.
BECAUSE WHEN HE GOES TO BED AT
NIGHT AND WHEN HE WAKES UP EVERY
SINGLE MORNING HE THINKS ABOUT
HOW HE CAN HELP AMERICAN
FAMILIES.
>> Reporter: BEING MESSENGER FOR
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS POLICIES
HAS BEEN A BIG PART OF BIDEN'S
BUSY YEAR.
PUTTING HER LITERALLY AND
FIGURATIVELY ALL OVER THE MAP,
APPEARING AT MORE THAN 150
EVENTS, TALKING UP EVERYTHING
FROM SCHOOLS AND CANCER RESEARCH
TO MILITARY FAMILIES, FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE, THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN, AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF GETTING VACCINATED.
BIDEN HAS PUT MORE DOMESTIC
MILES ON HER PLANE THAN EVEN THE
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT.
GOING TO A WHOPPING 35 STATES
THIS YEAR TO THE PRESIDENT'S 28.
>> OF COURSE YOU CAN.
THE BOSS IS GOING TO SAY
SOMETHING TO YOU.
>> Reporter: WHEN THE PRESIDENT
ISN'T ON THE ROAD, JILL OFTEN
IS.
>> FIRST LADY IS NOT A ROLE THAT
WE NECESSARILY CHOOSE, AND I
KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO HAVE A
HUSBAND WHO HAS TEN IDEAS FOR
HOW TO CHANGE THE WORLD BEFORE
YOU'VE EVEN HAD THAT FIRST CUP
OF COFFEE.
>> Reporter: SHE HAS BEEN JOE
BIDEN'S HYPE WOMAN.
>> I THINK HE'S SO PREPARED.
HE'S BEEN STUDYING FOR WEEKS.
JOE LOVES FOREIGN POLICY.
THIS IS HIS FORTE.
>> Reporter: GOING TO STATES
THAT DID NOT VOTE FOR HER
HUSBAND LIKE KENTUCKY WHERE THE
FIRST LADY ON FRIDAY VISITED
RESIDENTS DEALING WITH THE
AFTERMATH OF LAST MONTH'S DEADLY
TORNADOS.
>> IT WILL TAKE TIME TO MAKE
THIS BEAUTIFUL PLACE WHOLE
AGAIN, BUT WHAT WE'VE SEEN, WHAT
WE'VE ALL SEEN TODAY IS THERE IS
FAITH HERE, TOO.
>> Reporter: SHE'S CRISSCROSSED
AMERICA URGING PEOPLE TO GET THE
VACCINE.
>> I'M ASKING ALL OF YOU WHO ARE
LISTENING RIGHT NOW TO CHOOSE TO
GET VACCINATED.
>> Reporter: SHE'S USED HER EASY
APPROACHABILITY, HER CALL ME
GELATITUDE TO TRY TO BRING
TOGETHER A DIVIDED NATION IN A
YEAR THAT EVEN THIS SEASON A
POLITICAL SPOUSE HAS FOUND
CHALLENGING IN AN OCTOBER SPEECH
REVEALING THE JOB HAS NOT BEEN
EASY.
QUOTE, THERE ARE TIMES WHEN THE
ROLE OF FIRST LADY PUSHES YOU TO
SHOW UP EVEN WHEN IT'S
UNCOMFORTABLE.
WE ARE ELECTED.
WE HAVE TO DEFINE THIS ROLE FOR
OURSELVES, AND WE ARE THRUST
INTO A NATIONAL SPOTLIGHT IN A
WAY NONE OF US COULD HAVE
ANTICIPATED.
AT 70 BIDEN IS THE OLDEST
SITTING FIRST LADY IN MODERN
HISTORY, NOT THAT HAS SLOWED HER
DOWN.
THERE ARE MORE EVENTS, MORE
TRIPS AND MORE MESSAGES TO
DELIVER.
>> NOW, I KNOW THAT WE STILL
HAVE A LONG WAY